It could be said that the two most influential Britons of the past 30 years...
...are Tim Berners-Lee, who invented the World Wide Web,...
...and you, who have given us the iPod and all the train of Apple products.
And yet you both choose to live and work in America.
I wonder if that says something about Britain, or more importantly about America.
I think that there's just a conspicuous lack of cynicism and skepticism.
And ideas are so fragile, aren't they?
It's so easy to sort of miss an idea...
...because they can be so quiet, or to snuff an idea out.
I think that the sense of the inquisitiveness and the willingness to try is so important for design,...
...for developing those tentative, fragile ideas into a real product.